liberen los documentos ahora dice el
expresidente de eeuu donald trump en
respuesta a la solicitud del
departamento de justicia en eeuu para
desvelar la orden de registro que
permitió a los agentes del fbi registrar
su residencia de mar aragua no sólo no
me opondré a la liberación de documentos
a la redada antiamericana injustificada
e innecesaria voy a ir un paso más allá
al alentar a la liberación inmediata de
documentos aunque hayan sido elaborados
por demócratas radicales de izquierda y
posibles futuros oponentes políticos en
su declaración muy contundente continuó
con sus ataques al fbi desde que éste
registro su casa el lunes alegando que
su investigación estaba motivada
políticamente
tras una rara e inusual petición del
fiscal general de eeuu merrick garland a
un tribunal de florida para que haga
pública la orden judicial el funcionario
condenó el reciente aumento de los
ataques al fbi al final de su rueda de
prensa del jueves
permítanme abordar los recientes ataques
infundados a la profesionalidad de los
agentes y fiscales del fbi y del
departamento de justicia no me quedara
en silencio cuando se ataca injustamente
su integridad
la investigación criminal se centre en
si camps finalmente eliminó y destruyó
los registros de la casa blanca después
de dejar el cargo el año pasado el
diario estadounidense the washington
post citando fuentes anónimas dice que
el réferi estaba buscando documentos
sobre armas nucleares entre otros textos
clasificados garland señala que la
búsqueda se ajustó a la ley junto a
trump sus partidarios y otros
republicanos han expresado su opinión en
contra de la ferrari desde el registro
del lunes